[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich möchte euch eine frage stellen über
diese vielleicht schon einige leute
genannten gemacht haben wäre es möglich
dass den wichtigsten länder des nahen
ostens ihre differenzen ein für alle mal
beiseite legen und sich darauf einigen
eine gemeinsame verteidigung zu
organisieren zb gegen den iran so etwas
wie eine arabische nato oder ein
militärbündnis das sogar israel
einschließen könnte hört sich das nach
einer verrückten idee nun dann schaut
euch mal diese nachrichten etwas genauer
an
bestätigt die umsetzung eines regionalen
militärprojekt und zeigt damit seine
wachsende rolle der israelische
verteidigungsminister berlin ganz sagte
dass israel mit anderen ländern im nahen
osten zusammen arbeiten der
militärischen bedrohung durch den iran
entgegen zu treten
die israel arbeiter den arabischen
verbündeten zusammen um drohnen
abzuschießen ein zeichen für wachsende
beziehungen die zerstörung iranischer
drohnen im vergangenen jahr war ein
erstes beispiel für ein neues regionales
militärprojekt us präsident biden
während seines besuchs im nahen osten
vorantreiben will so überraschend es
auch sein mag viele in washington
reihten sich erleichtert die hände über
diese jüngste entwicklung auf den
geopolitischen schachbrett mit einer
solchen organisation könnte sich das
pentagon noch mehr auf seine eigentliche
priorität konzentrieren den asiatisch
pazifischen raum der iran wäre kein
problem mehr die ölfelder wären besser
geschützt und der nahe osten würde
wahrscheinlich die stabiler werden und
vergesst nicht dass wir über eine
regierung sprechen die die auch immer
wir sie betrachten weiterhin eine
schlüsselrolle in der weltwirtschaft
spielt zunächst einmal produziert diese
region nach wie vor mehr als 30 prozent
des weltweit verbrauchten erdöls
mit ausnahme des neuen israelischen
volkes dass man den usa gefördert wird
und über das nur sehr wenige details
bekannt sind war der versuch eine art
militärbündnis in dieser region der welt
zu schmieden bisher jedoch nie eine
einfache angelegenheit tatsächlich hat
es in der vergangenheit nur ein oder
zwei echte versuche gegeben etwas
ähnliches zu erreichen da wäre zum
beispiel der fall der central treaty
organisation stato mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wurde nämlich bereits einen
versuch unternommen eine nato in der
islamischen welt zwischen der türkei dem
irak und dem iran sowie anderen ländern
zu gründen der aber nicht einmal gestalt
annahmen allerdings endeten nicht alle
versuche in einem derartigen fiasko
der golfkooperationsrat in erster linie
einen wirtschafts und handelsbeziehungen
fast allen ländern der arabischen
halbinsel ist verfügt auch über einen
militärischen arms die peninsula schild
vor seine streitmacht von rund 40.000
soldaten welche die abschreckungskraft
stärken und den schutz und die
koordination zwischen den
mitgliedsländern verbessern soll und
auch weil viele von ihr noch nicht
gehört haben es handelt sich um eine
truppe die schon das ein oder andere mal
eingesetzt worden zum beispiel 2003 in
kuwait kostet vor den irak-krieg und
2011 auf besuchen der bahrainischen
regierung um eine zivil aufstand
niederzuschlagen
ein weiteres beispiel ist die arabische
liga die 2015 eine kleine gemeinsame
truppe von ebenfalls 40.000 soldaten
aufgestellt hat um auf mögliche krisen
in den mitgliedsstaaten zu reagieren in
diesem fall handelt es sich jedoch um
eine unterentwickelte vereinbarung mit
lehr unzureichend integrierten kräften
aber abgesehen von diesen begrenzten
beispielen in bezug auf fähigkeiten
integrationsfähigkeit weil er groß
angelegte gemeinsame verteidigung im
nahen osten bisher und denkbar wie
gesagt bisher denn wenn ihr das gesehen
habt was euch in diesem video zeigen
werden werdet ihr verstehen dass die
chance eine art keimzelle für eine neue
arabische nato zu schaffen so gut stehen
wie nie zuvor in der geschichte also
seid ihr gespannt wovon wir sprechen
dann lasst uns doch gleich nach einem
kurzen werbehinweis von unserem sponsor
servtag loslegen so scharf wie gehen ist
ein wirklich sicheres vpn welches zb
keinerlei verbindung staat mit lord
natürlich kann ein virtual private
network vpn einen nicht vor allen
gefahren schützen die ihn es lauern man
muss nach wie vor umsicht walten lassen
und wissen was man tut aber es stellt
hierfür ein werkzeug mit gleich mehreren
vorteilen da zum einen erschwerten
kombination mit anderen vorkehrungen
eure aktionen im netz nachzuverfolgen
und abzuhören mit hilfe verschiedener
sicherheitschefs könnt ihr zum beispiel
eure anonymität indes erhöhen zb mit dem
integrierten clean web dass alle cookies
und pop-ups blockt weiterer vorteil
eines vpn ist dass ihr so tun kann als
wäre die an einem anderen ort so könnte
zum beispiel auf websites und internet
dienste zugreifen die in dem land in dem
wir gerade seid nicht verfügbar wären ob
daheim oder im urlaub damit schlagt ihr
zensur und georg logging ein schnippchen
netflix und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten
ausnutzen oder deutsches internet fern
sind im ausland drucken mit surf kein
problem aber das ist lange noch nicht
alles denn mit nur einem server kommt
könnt ihr wirklich alle endgeräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
ihren smart tvs so und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angebt bekommt ihr
von cirque auch noch einen rabatt in
höhe von 83 prozent und obendrein den
ersten drei monate gratis dazu willst du
diesen angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besonders verschafft und
damit auch gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des pk
spenden links wenig ebenfalls eben die
beschreibung gepackt haben wir sind euch
für jede unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätte er uns euch in zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere videos zu liefern
so und dann schnell ab in den nahen
osten wo derzeit im windschatten der
russischen invasion in der ukraine
geschichte geschrieben wird
schaut euch mal die folgende nachricht
aus dem jahr 2018
dreizehnter september 2018 usa beginnen
gespräche mit arabischen vertretern über
ein regionales bündnis im stil der nato
der auslöser die zunehmende
kriegsveteranen und seiner punkt
programm das ihn in einer atommacht zu
verwandeln drohte und immer noch droht
gepaart mit seiner beachtlichen
ballistischen technologie in seinem
relativ starten militär all das hat die
wichtigsten arabischen erziehung des
sunnitischen zweigs des islam in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt
wie viele von euch bereits wissen gibt
es zwei große religiöse richtung im
islam die sunniten deren regionale
mächte saudi arabien und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate sind und die schiiten
deren wichtigste macht der iran ist die
sunnitischen länder von denen die
meisten im westen nahe stehen decken
schon einige jahre darüber nach das ist
vielleicht an der zeit bis schutz zu
suchen und miteinander zu kooperieren in
der iranischen bedrohung zu begegnen
schließlich versucht er russland und die
mit ihnen verbündeten nationen wie zb
auch der iran gerade angriffskriege zur
schaffung von territorialen tatsachen
wieder zu einem globalen standard zu
machen aber das kurioseste an der ganzen
geschichte ist noch nicht mal der
plötzliche arabische kooperations fälle
sondern für alle nationen die eine
führende rolle dabei spielt länder wie
saudi arabien die vereinigten arabischen
emirate bahrain kuwait und ägypten dazu
zu bringen ihre verhältnis untereinander
zu glätten um mit der iranischen
bedrohung und dem radikal terrorismus
fertig zu lernen und vergesst nicht dass
wir keineswegs über ein eher
unbedeutendes potenzielles bündel
sprechen von irgendwelchen militärischen
kinkerlitzchen
[Musik]
nein die länder der arabischen halbinsel
mit auch so wird es jemanden geben jedes
jahr etwa 120 milliarden dollar für die
verteidigung aus ein budget das fast so
hoch ist wie das großbritanniens
frankreichs und deutschlands
zusammengenommen ein budget das auch
fast der hälfte der gesamten
militärausgaben chinas entspricht wir
haben ist somit alles andere als eine
bagatelle zu tun aber was genau ist
eigentlich die eben erwähnte kuriosität
nun das land das gerade versucht die
großen schwergewichte der arabischen
welt zusammenzubringen um einen liter
bundes zu schmieden und sich dabei
selbst in die mitte stellt ist kein
anderes als genau israel aber moment mal
israel das gleiche israel welches von
den eben genannten arabischen ländern
selbst viele jahrzehnte lang bedroht und
ins visier genommen wurde jenes land
dessen bürger bis vor kurzem noch nicht
mal in den meisten dieser länder
einreisen durften ja selbst ein
israelischer diesen stempel in einem eu
pass konnte euch dort probleme bereiten
also soll das ganze ein scherz sein nun
so überraschend es auch vorkommen mag
die wahrheit ist nein das alles ist kein
witz es ist geradezu unglaublich und
atemberaubend wie sich das blatt in nur
wenigen jahren derart radikal gewendet
hat
1948 56 67 73 82 in all diesen jahren
befanden sich verschiedene arabische
staaten auf die ein oder andere weise
direkt oder indirekt im krieg oder in
einer tödlichen konfrontation mit israel
länder wie ägypten und jordanien sich
aus verschiedenen gründen mehrmals im
krieg mit den jüdischen staat und selbst
die überwiegende mehrheit der arabischen
länder die nicht in den krieg gegen
israel gezogen sind hatten nicht nur
eine starke abneigung gegen das land der
hebräer sein weigerten sich auch israel
als staat anzuerkennen
sie finanzierten den kampf der
palästinensischen araber und verhängten
handelsblockaden und wirtschaft strafen
aller art gegen dieses land meiner
lieben visual politik zuschauer all das
was sich jetzt grundlegend geändert
israel ist nicht nur nicht mehr der
vater arabischen welt wird für bestimmt
ist sehr mächtige teile davon sogar zu
einem wertvoll verbündeten und mit dem
militärischen vereinbarungen aktiv in
betracht gezogen werden denn vergesst
nicht dass israel nicht nur über eines
der effektivsten und technologisch
fortschrittlichsten militärs der welt
verfügt und eine der schlagkräftigsten
geheimdiensten hat sondern auch eine
nukleare supermacht ist eine macht also
die man lieber als freund denn als feind
haben möchte also aufgepasst
die navy und tritt die organisation kurz
nato
wenn es etwas gibt das in der
islamischen welt endemisch zu sein
scheint dann ist es die unfähigkeit
wichtige kollektive vereinbarungen zu
treffen und wenn es um fragen der
verteidigung oder der sicherheit geht
werden die dinge noch komplizierter bis
heute ist so gut wie jeder versuch in
diese richtung zu gehen auf die harten
realitäten der region gestoßen eine
region in der keiner dem anderen traut
aber passt ist gut auf denn hier könnten
gerade jetzt von nichts geringerem als
vor einem wendepunkt der weltgeschichte
stehen
der negev gipfel fördert die
arabisch-israelische normalisierung die
hausgemachten gespräche signalisieren
wachsende regionale beziehungen trotz
fehlender fortschritte bei der zwei
staaten lösung
israel bekundet interesse an einem nato
ähnlichen bündnis im nahen osten ok aber
was in aller welt liegt im rahmen dieses
gipfeltreffens in der wüste negev ab nun
am 27 28 märz 2022 trafen sich ins depot
einem kleinen wüsten keynotes hohe
vertreter der vereinigten arabischen
emirate bahrain ägypten markus israels
und der usa
das ziel war es israel und die
arabischen länder einander näher zu
bringen die regierung beiden führt somit
konsequent ihren weg fort im trump mit
dem abkommen eingeleitet hatte
denn es stellt sich heraus dass israel
sehr gute beziehungen zu den arabischen
ländern ermittelt mit denen es
vereinbarungen aller art trifft
insbesondere mit den schwerreichen und
ambitionierten vereinigten arabischen
emirate hier kann man mittlerweile gab
und überaus freundschaftlichen
beziehungen sprechen die wir anfang des
videos gesehen haben sogar enge
militärische zusammenarbeit ermöglichen
habt ihr zum beispiel die folgende
nachricht mitbekommen
dies bestätigt die umsetzung eines
regionalen militärprojekt und zeigt
damit seine wachsende rolle der
israelische verteidigungsminister bei
dir ganz sagte dass israel mit anderen
ländern im nahen osten zusammen arbeite
um der militärischen bedrohung durch den
iran entgegen zu treten die israel will
eine wichtige rolle bei der führung
eines neuen regionalen block spielen
heute ist das am besten vorbereitete
land in der region um teheran von
stoppen oder zumindest aufzuschrecken es
verfügt über eine der schlagkräftigsten
armeen der welt und seinem militär
industrie ist technologisch führend aber
wie ich bereits sagte ist das gerede
über eine große militärbündnis in der
region nichts neues bereits die
regierung obama war bestrebt sich ein
für alle mal aus dem nahen osten zurück
zu ziehen und ihre aufgaben an ein
solches bündnis zu delegieren
[Musik]
ok zumindest begann man diese option zu
prüfen und später förderte die
kompensation insbesondere micro bio die
sogenannte mittel die strategic alliance
meaa eine organisation die einen
stärkeren militärische koordinierung
zwischen den ländern des
golfkooperationsrates ägypten jordanien
und den vereinigten staaten selbst
anstrebt doch auch wenn leser mit den
regierungswechsel in den usa auf eis
gelegt wurde gib deine gipfel der von
nun an jährlich stattfinden soll anlass
zur hoffnung vor allem weil nun auch
israel mit macht und weil die usa
entschlossen zu sein scheinen eine
weitaus distanzierte rolle in bezug auf
die probleme dieser region einzunehmen
außerdem könnte ein bündnis das israel
einschließt nicht nur im militärischen
bereich funktionieren sondern auch im
bereich der sicherheit und entwicklung
und das könnte im nahen osten so
wahrlich gravierende veränderungen
führen denn diese neue organisation
könnte nicht nur den iran schachmatt
setzen nein die zusammenarbeit könnte
noch viel weiter gehen und dinge die die
sicherheit der wasserversorgung den
intensiven einsatz von spezialeinheiten
und die verhinderung von bürgerkriegen
durch den einsatz von friedenstruppen
umfassen diese stabilisierende und
wohlstands fördernde wirkung konnte das
politische wirtschaftliche die
gesellschaftliche gesicht des ganzen
nahen ostens um seine bedeutung in der
ganzen welt grundlegend zum besseren
verändern die spirale aus misstrauen und
hass könnte endlich durchbrochen oder
zumindest umgekehrt werden aufklärung
und moderne könnten in der breiten
bevölkerung fuß fassen könnte dieser
weltregionen mit ihren rund 370
millionen einwohnern mit diesem schritt
also eine echte renaissance bevorstehen
naja wie immer ist ist natürlich die
eine sache etwas zu wollen und eine ganz
andere es auch wirklich hin zu bekommen
also was sind denn die größten
herausforderungen auf diesem weg
aufgepasst
wie auf dem basar
es handelt sich um kein großes geheimnis
die arabische welt vor einer einigung
einen wichtigen fragen zu bewegen ist
komplizierter also selbst einen wladimir
putin zur vernunft zu bringen und
bedenkt bitte folgendes wenn es schon
kompliziert ist in asien ein
militärbündnis zu schließen dann stellt
euch vor was ist bedeutet dies in einer
region zu tun in der die religiöse frage
alles durchzieht und in der in
militärischen und sicherheitspolitischen
fragen die interessen der verschiedenen
königshäuser oft schwerer wiegen als die
allgemeinen interessen der menschen der
vielleicht größte stolperstein bleibt
saudi arabien die beziehungen zwischen
riad und jerusalem haben sich zwar stark
verbessert aber sie stagnieren immer
noch weitaus mehr als die beziehungen
israels zu anderen arabischen ländern
aufbauen konnte so hat er ja zum
beispiel noch keine formellen
diplomatischen beziehungen aufgenommen
und beschlossen den abraham abkommen
keine große beachtung zu schenken dass
der gedanke an ein militär- oder
sicherheitsbündnis heute undenkbar
erscheint und natürlich wäre es auch für
das haus saud nicht akzeptabel wenn ein
solches bündnis ohne seine beteiligung
zustande käme dies würde unter anderem
bedeuten dass ist eine führungsrolle in
der arabischen welt verlieren würde die
sau diesem fall wieder diejenigen die
von allen anderen gewaschen werden
wollen ohne selbst dabei nass zu werden
andererseits wissen wir auch dass die
herrscher in riad wie immer programme um
die besten konditionen für sich heraus
zu bekommen um dann lässt sich doch
wieder in den schoß des westens
zurückzukehren ein spiel welches sie
auch in den usa und russland spielen wir
euch bereits in einem früheren video
erklärt haben ich werde euch natürlich
verlinken
[Musik]
allerdings sind die saudis nicht die
einzige nuss die es zu knacken gilt
katar das auch mitglied des
golfkooperationsrates ist versteht sich
zwar ausgezeichnete den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten hat jedoch ein
turbulentes verhältnis zu saudi arabien
und verbessert nach und nach auch noch
seine bilateralen beziehungen zum iran
die gründe nur zum einen ball ist große
gasfelder mit dem iran teilt zum anderen
weil duo erhofft so etwas wie ein
bindeglied zwischen teheran und
washington zu werden
katars botschafter in iran betont
wachsende bilaterale beziehungen
[Musik]
katars außenminister schließt
normalisierung mit israel aus aber wie
gesagt letztlich könnten auch im falle
kataris die usa helfen einer den
inselstaat gesichtswahrende wie
hochgradig lukrative lösung zu finden
über den gas macht katar und ihre rolle
in der durch russland ausgelöst
energiekrise werden wir übrigens schon
bald ein eigenes video drehen vergesst
also bitte nicht das abo und ganz
richtig voran das glöckchen damit ihr
unserer spannenden videos in der
riesigen youtube flut nicht mehr
verpasst saudi arabien und katar sind
also die größten stolpersteine auf der
reise des nahen ostens in eine neue
zukunft noch würden sie eine
herausforderung allerdings wissen wir
schon heute dass es eine militärische
struktur gibt eine allianz zwischen
israel und den arabischen ländern die
führenden köpfe dieser allianz und vor
allem israels haben den ehrgeiz eine
viel wichtigere rolle im nahen osten zu
spielen und bei diesem ziel liebesorte
des vereins handelt es sich leider
gesehen haben nicht um eine kleinigkeit
wir bleiben daher am ball und werden
euch schon bald das nächste puzzlestück
in diesen geopolitischen machtspiel
präsentieren aber jetzt seid ihr erst
mal an der reihe glaubt ihr dass der im
nahen osten niemals ein militärbündnis
im stile nato sehen werden was denkt ihr
welche rolle israel in militärischen
angelegenheiten nachdem abraham abkommen
und den bgf dialogen spielen wird wie
immer freuen wir uns schon auf eure
kultivierten kommentare und angeregten
diskussion ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und vielleicht aber
auch etwas gelernt habt was ja geht uns
bitte ein leichtes auch fleißig mit
euren freunden und natürlich folgt uns
auf die derzeit über eine spende von
euch mit der uns hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen den paper link dazu
findet in der beschreibung oder dem
video als gut und bis bald
[Musik]